m
[Musique]
événement
24 vous fait vivre l'élection
présidentielle française
cette année le président macron
sera-t-il réélu pour cinq ans ou
sera-t-il battu par l'un des candidats
déterminés à le faire tomber
france24 ouvre la campagne électorale et
va à la rencontre des français des
candidats et de leurs soutiens
suivez l'élection présidentielle
française tous les jours sur france 24
et france 24 points comme
salut à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce 5ème live c'est le complément de
notre émission france 2022 lors du choix
consacrez vous le savez la
présidentielle ici en france j - 4
désormais avant le second tour c'est la
toute dernière ligne droite et vous le
savez ce soir c'est le moment tant
attendu du grand débat de l'entre-deux
tour entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron grand débat que vous pourrez
suivre suivre d'ailleurs en direct sur
notre antenne dans le cas d'une édition
spéciale qui commence à 20h15 heure de
paris vous pourrez aussi suivre
d'ailleurs cette édition spéciale sur ce
live
ce rendez-vous d'entre deux tours cela
rendez vous incontournable qui peut
confirmer une dynamique déjà en place en
faveur d'un candidat ou au contraire
desservir un autre candidat bref un
exercice crucial pour pour ses candidats
lors on imagine que vous avez déjà
beaucoup de questions n'hésitez pas à
nous les poser dès à présent sur le
facebook live et le youtube live et vous
le savez avec mon équipe ici en région
va recueillir donc toutes ces questions
ont essayé de répondre un maximum
d'entre vous alors avant de retrouver
comme le veut la tradition notre la chef
du service politique de france 24
roselyne faire avec qui donc on va on va
remettre aussi se débat dans une
perspective historique j'ai le plaisir
d'être pour le début de ce live avec mon
collègue clovis casali qu'on a
d'ailleurs aussi l'habitude
d'avoir dans ce live merci beaucoup
clovis de me joindre à nouveau pour ce
5ème live donc c'est un live disons
crucial lui aussi puisqu'on parle donc
de ce débat crucial de l'entre-deux
tours qui est notamment
disons très important pour marine le pen
on s'en rappelle il ya cinq ans en 2017
lors du débat de l'entre-deux tours qui
était déjà contre emmanuel macron qui
était donc pas président sortant à
l'époque mais bon elle l'avait
complètement raté d un trait par est un
désastre un désastre elle était arrivée
très très fatiguée et depuis son
entourage ne cessé de rappeler qu'elle
était furieuse contre son entourage
notamment pour avoir organisé la veille
une rencontre avec une association
africaine attend jusqu'à une heure du
matin dans un hôtel du 15e
arrondissement de paris qui selon elle
ne servait à rien puisqu'il fallait se
préparer emmanuel macron de l'autre côté
avait pris plusieurs jours au calme au
repos pour préparer son débat marine le
pen elle était arrivée exténué elle
avait multiplié les déplacements donc
juste avant ce débat et vous en rappeler
ça c'était super mal passé pour elle il
y avait des plans de coupe du
réalisateur on la voyait en train de
regarder dans ses fiches et c'est alors
que emmanuel macron lui paraissait
beaucoup plus calme paraissait beaucoup
plus posé et on se rappelle tous de ces
images de marine le pen un peu agressive
un peu nerveuse bref elle avait
complètement raté son départ ainsi
confondu entre sfr et et alstom c'était
compliqué pour elle c'était très très
compliqué
c'est marrant parce que je crois que
juste après ce débat là et perdu trois
points dans les sondages et donc c'était
forcément un moment qu'elle veut oublier
mais elle dit qu'elle a changé elle
admet qu' c'est un désastre à l'époque
son entourage aussi et ses partisans ces
militants qu'on a rencontrés nous dise
où elle a été catastrophique pendant le
débat eric zemmour l'a beaucoup
critiquée sur sa dette d'ailleurs c'est
quoi leur état d'esprit aujourd'hui
confiants ils sont plutôt confiant il
pense qu'elle est mieux préparée qu'elle
a changé que sa stratégie de
dédiabolisation à marcher que c'est la
bonne stratégie c'est pour ça qu'elle
est au second tour notamment qu'elle
arrive la meute c'est pour ça qu'elle a
réussi à passer devant eric zémour haut
la main et une non ils sont plutôt
confiants ils se disent qu'elle est
préparée que c'est le moment et cette
fois ci j'ai parlé tout à l'heure avec
quelqu'un de l'entourage de marine le
pen qui est très proche d'elle et qui me
disait que cette fois ci ça va être
projet contre projet plus bilan
c'est-à-dire marine le pen va présenter
son projet
marc emmanuel macron le président
sortant va défendre le sien mais il va
aussi défendre son bilan et ça c'est un
point crucial la cinq ans ce n'était pas
la même chose et donc c'est pour ça que
marine le pen essaie de faire se feront
tous sentis macro l'un est justement tu
dirais que emmanuel macron lie dans une
position disons beaucoup plus
inconfortable puisqu'il va devoir
défendre son bilan dans un sens
favorable au final cet exercice ça
dépend si tu penses que bilan des
manuels macro est bon parce que lui va
il va mettre en avant les qualités
internationales ce qu'il a réussi à
faire sur l'ukraine la maison qu'il a
géré la crise du coc vide et de l'autre
côté tu as marine le pen qui va
légèrement justement vous avez fait
n'importe quoi sur le co vite avec les
gilet jaune marine le pen qui a lancé un
peu un appel au gilet jaune un appel du
pied au moins avec ce fameux référendum
d'initiative populaire tu sais cinq cent
mille signatures d'électeurs qui peuvent
poser n'a pour ensuite voilà pour poser
n'importe quelle question
qui passe ensuite en référendum et
marine le pen d'ailleurs veut que le
premier soit sur l'immigration
l'immigration massive selon elle donc ça
c'est un point important est pour elle
c'est une manière de doute repasser de
de dépasser un petit peu le parlement
même la cour constitutionnelle et le
conseil constitutionnel et pour poser la
question directement aux français pour
changer à la société marine le pen qui
vraiment on va proposer une vision
radicalement différente de celle d'
emmanuel macron bien sûr et sur quoi tu
penses qu'elle risque de l'attaqué
principalement alors qu'à évoquer les
questions internationales la crise
ukrainienne là il était plutôt à son
avantage
sur quel sur quel thème sur lequel
elle va dire le président macron c'est
le président des riches elle le répète
dans tous ses missions l'entendue à
perpignan avignon noir elle va aussi
rappeler à la ferme et kenzy avec
notamment les cabinets de conseil qui
conseille mais pour des milliards
d'euros et est beaucoup sollicité femme
beaucoup plus que dans leur passé sous
le quinquennat macron voilà et donc elle
va être elle va l'attaquer sur ça en
gros c'est très simple marine le pen
elle dit que mais emmanuel macron c'est
le président de la mondialisation le
président des élites et quelle est la
présidente elle sera la présidente du
monde rurale de la france des oubliés
mais aussi dans les villes moyennes de
tous les français qui sont abandonnés
selon elle par les gouvernants depuis
des dizaines d'années et elle va répéter
tout simplement que emmanuel macron
propose une vision qu'est ce qu'elle
disait que la vision d' emmanuel macron
était une vision ou voilà l'homme
étaient asservis à la logique économique
ou l'homme n'était qu'un simple
consommateur qu'on autorisés à traverser
les frontières alors qu'elle propose une
vision où l'homme en fait on revient au
local et où l'homme n'est pas simplement
un consommateur et c'est marrant parce
que en fait m marine le pen elle propose
une vision quasiment anti capitaliste si
on veut selon elle en tout cas elle se
dit du côté des patriotes contre
emmanuel macron le camp des de la
mondialisation alors il ya une première
question à clovis de dieudonné jake dème
merci beaucoup de nous avoir écrit à
dieudonné les russes vont ils intervenir
dans cette élection pour faire perdre
emmanuel macron bon alors que mandanda
fait référence au lien
entre la candidate du rassemblement
national et la russie peut-être aussi en
campagne chic dans le passé sont disons
sa
bienveillance et la migration en fer
vladimir poutine est ce que tu peux un
peu on peut parler ça en acceptant les
campagnes de déstabilisation des russes
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit pour
le vote sur le break site que soi même
par exemple pour l'élection de trump
s'est il ya eu beaucoup d'accusations à
ce niveau là est-ce que les ruses on
essaie de déstabiliser cette élection
c'est fort possible on sait qu'il ya des
des hackers en russie on sait qu'à des
groupes très très organisés alors est ce
qui suit travaillent directement pour le
kremlin saas et des accusations mais est
ce que la russie a intérêt à ce que
marine le pen soit u présidente
certainement tout simplement parce que
marine le pen propose une vision r c'est
quoi justement son positionnement par
rapport à la russie en quoi est-ce
qu'elle diffère de mais en fait surtout
en fait ce qui est important c'est
qu'elle propose une vision de l'union
européenne qui n'est pas une union qui
est une alliance des nations et ça c'est
un peu miné le projet européen et c'est
ce que souhaitent les russes c'est ce
que les russes encouragent depuis des
années ils ont toujours encouragé les
mouvements eurosceptiques en europe même
si elle se défend de vouloir sortir de
l'ue eux mais en fait ce programme est
la vue d'aller dans des nations elle
veut une alliance des nations et oui
elle veut plus sortir de l'euro de
l'union en tout cas c'est ce qu'elle dit
elle veut refondre entièrement mais si
tu payes pas les cotisations si tu
décides de ne pas créer des politiques
communes et des politiques nationales
c'est plus l'europe qu'on connaît alors
par rapport à ce que tu disais par
rapport à la russie il y a des liens
depuis longtemps en 2010 est elle allée
à moscou elle dit que c'était la seule
fois qu'elle rencontre et de la dîme à
poutine elle en est sortie rang en
vantant les mérites un peu de la vision
de boutines de l'histoire du nouveau
monde elle disait avec les trump poutine
maudit en inde
et après il y à ces fameux prêt je pense
que non c'est ce que tu voulais dire les
prêts russe ou en faite le au
rassemblement national a contracté des
prêts et les créanciers sont russes on
parle de millions d'euros acquis que le
rnd doit à des créanciers russes mais
elle dit bas les banques françaises
voulaient pas nous prêter on s'est
tourné vers les russes et ses leçons des
prêts à 6 % d'intérêt donc vous
inquiétez pas rien à craindre de ce côté
là alors pas mal de questions qui nous
arrive l'une de maria alexandre videira
bonjour maria merci pour cette question
alors que marine le pen parle de
l'économie sérieusement di maria avec
des chiffres et pour l'environnement
katell l'intention de faire et aussi
pour aider l'ukraine mans il ya beaucoup
d'eux alors de gêne donc l'économie
l'environnement l'ukraine rapidement si
tu peux en tout cas fort l'économie
c'est simple elle est énormément de
baisses d'impôts il ya des primes pas
d'impôt sur le revenu pour les moins de
30 ans
elle souhaite un panier de 100 produits
dits essentiels à eghezée raw % de tva
beaucoup de baisses d'impôts comment
elle le financer ma avec la priorité
nationale une prestation sociale de
logement pour les étrangers comment les
finances a aussi peut-être en cotisant
moins au niveau européen et marine le
pen veut aussi ça c'est un gros volet de
son programme combattre la fraude
sociale mais c'est compliqué de la
fraude sociale et la fraude financière
l'évasion fiscale c'est compliqué de
chiffrer combien l'état français va
pouvoir récupérer 2 milliards
il est acquis et de taquet sur ça il ya
plein de ces mesures notamment des
baisses d'impôts qui
sont pas vraiment en phase avec les
règles européennes sur l'écologie elle
elle me sûr le tout nucléaire est elle
mise sur le localisme donc en fait elle
veut beaucoup plus de circuits courts
revenir
au niveau local au terroir et elle se
dit par exemple amis des bêtes alors je
sais pas si on met ça dans l'allée que
l'écologie mais en tout cas les chats
notamment mais même elle veut pas
forcément statuer sur la chasse mais
elle elle se dit admis des animaux du
monde des animaux et c est au niveau de
l'écologie elle elle se dit écologique
mais c'est clairement pas comme les
verts et d'europe écologie les verts
même jean lui même jean luc mélenchon si
on veut donc elle risque d'être attaqué
sur sa part emmanuel macron et sur
l'ukraine moi je lui ai posé la question
si vous êtes présidente qu'est ce que
vous faites par rapport à l'ukraine est
ce que vous armer les ukrainiens et elle
m'a répondu oui j'en vois des armes
défensives et du renseignement mais rien
qui puisse faire de la france un
belligérant un kobe lit géant si elle
est élue
et c'est vrai qu'elle a condamné très
rapidement l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
mais en même temps en 2014
quand il ya eu la crimée la sphère de la
crimée elle s'était opposée aux
sanctions européennes contre la russie
et elle est toujours contre les
sanctions par exemple sur le gaz russe
en fait ce qu'elle dit c'est simple
c'est aucune sanction contre la russie
qui pourrait pénaliser la france est
donc à le gaz il j donc c'est ménager un
petit peu c'est la chèvre et le chou
c'est ça l'expression
petite question de boris boussamba
bonjour maurice quels seront les
rapports sociaux économiques voire
militaire entre la france et l'afrique
si marine le pen remporte cette élection
en gros quel refondations est ce qu'il y
aura d'ailleurs une refondation des
relations entre la france et l'afrique
si elle est nue mais alors déjà faux
depuis c'est intéressant parce que le
rassemblement national c'est son ancêtre
c'est le front national le front
national c'est beaucoup c'est notamment
des anciens de l'algérie qui avait
vraiment la dent dure par rapport à ce
qui s'était passé le retrait la fin de
la guerre d'algérie et c'est maintenant
marine le pen elle évolue un peu sur ces
thèmes là en gros elle dit qu'elle veut
avoir des relations fortes avec les
nations en afrique et en même temps pas
trop intervenir je me rappelle il ya
très longtemps elle disait qu'elle était
au début favorable je crois à la à
l'invasion enfin la aux opérations en
libye ensuite alors changé d'avis en
fait elles changent beaucoup d'avis à ce
niveau là et puis j'ai d'ailleurs où il
ya eu pas mal de revirements d'ailleurs
pendant sept ans entre voilà alors après
il ya eu le mali par exemple le mali
avec la junte malienne là elle a eu un
message de fermeté en disant c'est
inacceptable que les maliens expulse les
diplomates français de cette manière là
faut être ferme ils veulent pas d'eux
ils veulent ils veulent nous faire payer
à la situation ils veulent ils sont durs
avec nous on sera dur avec le alors ça
veut dire aussi beaucoup moins de visas
pour les ressortissants il ya ça aussi
par rapport aux algériens et tous les
pays africains par exemple qu'ils
refusent de reprendre leurs
ressortissants qu'elle souhaite voir
expulser et bains où des gens qui par
exemple ont commis des crimes ou qui
sont fichés s etc ce camp que les pays
veulent pas les accueillir je crois que
c'est le cas avec l'algérie pour un
certain nombre là elle veut
drastiquement couper le nombre de visas
n'autoriser aucun chef d'état ou hommes
politiques ou hommes d'affaires disons
algériens ou autres de venir en france
donc elle veut une politique de fermeté
par rapport à ça ce qu'elle appelle un
peu la réciprocité peut-être une
dernière question pour toi clovis de
mauricie 10 mai bonjour maury emmanuel
macron at-il la confiance du peuple
français donc après cinq années au
pouvoir ça dépend ça dépend on saura on
saura dimanche
c'est 50
4 voilà 54% pour emmanuel macron environ
entre 46% à priori en tout cas c'était
le cas hier pour marine le pen ouais bah
c'est compliqué à dire yako en fait le
problème c'est que le emmanuel macron
soit on a confiance en lui soit on le
déteste enfance c'est le beau coup de sa
ya beaucoup de gens même à gauche qui
hésitent à aller voter pour pour
emmanuel macron parce qu'il trouve qu'il
est trop à droite tu as beaucoup de gens
qui rejettent un petit peu
la manière dont il a gouverné en pensant
qu'il a trop gouverner pour les riches
soit disant enfin c'est ce qu'ils
pensent il ya des endroits en france où
des des fiefs un peu gilet jaune on le
moment d'un gilet jaune c'était aussi
dirigé contre emmanuel macron donc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui lui en veulent et
qui savent pas s'ils vont voter pour lui
où voter pour lui pour faire barrage à
marine le pen et ce qui est intéressant
c'est quelqu'un dans l'entourage de
marine le pen le disait aussi été très
con tour du dernier sondage qui est
qu'ils arrivent et c'est un sondage bfm
cette fois ci qui disait que 25 % des
français ne savait pas encore pour qui
ils allaient voter des indécis qui
attendaient ce débat de l'entre-deux
tours pour ensuite voter soit pour
marine le pen soit pour mme emmanuelle
macro et là l'écart est tellement réduit
comparé à 2010 est que forcément l'eau
quand le pen est très très motivés très
mobilisés pense que ils sont plus que
jamais aux portes du pouvoir donc est ce
que les gars un barrage contre le rn
comme à l'époque en 2002 contre le fn il
ya 20 ans c'est intéressant quand même
20 empilant avec jean marie le pen qui
accèdent au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
avec ces manifestations monstres dans
tout le pays là on n'a pas eu ça bien
c'est pas la même ambiance merci
beaucoup clovis pour voilà d'avoir
répondu à toutes les questions de nos
internautes et donc on va te suivre dans
cette dernière ligne droite sur nos
chaînes à la fois franco et englos et
puis tout et reportages de campagne sont
aussi retrouvés sur notre site internet
en france lancera son race demain matin
pour suivre le dernier meeting de marine
se voir dans notre émission
dimanche bien sûr au qg ça a changé
avant c'était au château de 20 à côté du
château de vincennes au premier tour là
cette fois ci c'est dans l'ouest
parisien beaucoup de gens suivre à sa
merci beaucoup clovis d'être venu merci
à vous tous qui nous poser toutes ces
questions en direct sur youtube et
facebook et donc à ceux qui sont déjà là
ce qu'ils sont en train de nous
rejoindre à l'instant sur ce live donc
de notre émission sur france 24 france
2022 lors du choix consacré à la
présidentielle on est donc toujours
ensemble pour répondre à toutes vos
questions aux interrogations sur notre
émission sur notre ligne éditoriale et
puis sur le thème du jour que je vous
rappelle le débat crucial de
l'entre-deux-tours bien sûr
avoir d'ailleurs sur notre antenne ce
soir à partir de 20h15 heure de paris le
début de notre édition spéciale et puis
ce débat entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen devrait démarrer vers 21h heure
de paris roselyne febvre la chef du
service politique de france 24 nous a
rejoint bonjour roselyne
avant ce débat de l'entre-deux tours on
va suivre ça c'est deux heures trente de
débat a priori c'est un exercice quand
même très éprouvant pour les deux
candidats qui s'y prépare c'est direct
est le point d'orgue de cette de cette
campagne oui oui il va au moins se
passer quelque chose se soit enfin on
espère entre les deux candidats c'est
vrai qu'on a eu une campagne
complètement mollassonne et complètement
percuté il est vrai par la guerre en
ukraine ce qui a permis d'ailleurs
de poser pour les uns et les autres pour
tous les candidats aussi leur leur
posture internationale donc ce qui
n'était pas totalement inintéressant
mais il n'y a pas eu de débat il n'y a
pas eu de confrontation et dans le fond
la campagne s'est vraiment déroulée sur
les plateaux de télé et puis quelques
meetings par ci par là alors on a déjà
une petite question concernant donc la
fiche de ce second tour de simon gia je
ne comprends pas que certains français
fasse comme si le fait que l'extrême
droite soit au second tour n'était pas
très grave donc en gros une question sur
ben
oui la banalisation de l'extrême droite
dans cette élection oui c'est vrai la
banalisation des clovis évoqué il ya 20
ans voilà c'est une manifestation
monstre là c'est vraiment une autre
ambiance c'est une autre ambiance
alors là on voit quand même c'est depuis
ces derniers temps quand même que la
presse
commence à faire d une un peu un peu
punk chier sur presse de gauche la
presse de gauche génération mais
d'autres d'autres presse comme par
exemple le parisien qui depuis quelques
jours quand même fait sa une où on
laisse entendre que le programme n'est
pas très sérieux de marine le pen où il
ya eu notamment il ya deux jours tout un
sujet sur la russie aussi voilà donc on
sent que la presse ça s'agite un peu
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai il n'ya pas ça s'est
banalisé c'est à dire l'extrême droite
présente au second tour ça fait la
troisième fois donc ça a été un des uns
des déflagrations en 2002 avec marie et
jean marie le pen avec marine le pen
aussi en 2017 et puis c'est vrai donc la
ccc j'en ai envie de dire circulez ya
rien à voir
question de palme h delpech merci
beaucoup pour cette question pensez vous
que marine le pen sera à la hauteur ce
soir échos sans aucun doute à sa
prestation ratée de 2017 la fin d'une
autre marine le pen va se présenter ce
soir ça en tweets sans doute ça à mon
avis je pense qu'elle s'est vraiment la
cata l info oui c'était c'était on
l'avait perdu elle s'est perdue elle
même est d'ailleurs elle a eu du mal à
s'en remettre politiquement et
personnellement aujourd'hui quand on
demande à son entourage ils vous disent
qu effectivement s'est préparée elle
s'est remise à cheval quelque temps
après ça ce bouillon on va dire cette
catastrophe et elle a été elle a été
travaillée
travailler ses dossiers parce que vous
vous souvenez elle avait confondu sur le
dossier alstom les turbines et des
téléphones et puis elle était perçue
entre alstom et sfr oui c'est pour ça
que je dis les turbines e et laisser
faire et les téléphones donc
aujourd'hui oui on peut imaginer qu'elle
quelques elle travaillera son sujet
qu'elle aura donc bossé ces dossiers
le débat va commencer par le pouvoir
d'achat donc ça c'est plutôt que ça a
été tiré au sort donc là pour le coup
c'est
la chance parce que c'est son sujet de
prédilection c'est le sujet de la baisse
elle a eu le flair depuis septembre mais
avant même la gare en ukraine voilà que
ce serait le sujet de la présidentielle
deuxième sujet ce serait effectivement
la politique étrangère est là pour le
coup emmanuel macron c'est peut-être là
que ça peut frites et un peu plus mais
de toute façon emmanuel macron
alors surtout chacun aura compris qu'il
faut pas s'énerver qu'il faut pas être
agressif parce que ça c'est
contre-productif donc chacun va amener
dans le fond son projet contre projet
emmanuel macron avant
je fais prête à mettre ma main à couper
qu'il dira tout ça n'est pas sérieux
comment vous financez ça vous proposait
de baisser la contribution à l'union
européenne mais ça veut dire quoi est ce
que ça veut dire qu'on sort des traités
voulaient nos repas la carte et cédera
donc là on va voir ce qu'elle va
répondre ils risquent effectivement d'y
avoir de la part d' emmanuel macron qui
ne pourra pas s'empêcher à un moment ou
un autre de jouer le professeur alors
une
un commentaire la tendance ah oui non
pardon une question de vazy turcomans
marine le pen envisage-t-elle de combler
la plus value apportée par les étrangers
qui seront poussés hors de la france ou
alors question sur les intentions de
marine le pen si elle est élue
concernant les étrangers qui se situe en
france est ce qu'on s'est un peu parce
qu'elle a dit clairement oui belle
d'abord elle a énoncé sa fameuse
priorité nationale 1 donc pour ceux qui
pour accéder notamment logement et c'est
donc là ce sont les familles françaises
donc moi j'avais sur le avec frédéric
rivière hier nous avions le porte parole
de marine le pen on lui demandait
justement ben alors les gens qui
bénéficient d'un appartement
et qui sont étrangers qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors bien évidemment non on ne va
pas les expulser
l'argument elle en tout cas de marine le
pen sur les étrangers c'est de les
raccompagner dans leur pays
ceux en tout cas qui sont en situation
irrégulière
mais la difficulté on le sait bien c'est
le retour dans le pays parce que
certains pays ne veulent pas récupérer
leurs ressortissants
pour elle c'est toujours le même slogan
immigration zéro donc pas de nouveaux
étrangers
immigration zéro en revanche on applique
le droit d'asile
question de dre boni griga
macron gagnera mais il perdra les
législatives
bon on s'avance un petit pansement
sommes un peu mais on va peut-être pas
alors luc mélenchon oui alors allez lire
premier ministre à l'issue d'une
troisième tour à savoir les législatives
il a ses chances
scénario qui s'est en tout cas c'est un
bon coup politique de dire préau les
gapençais à moi pour être premier
ministre et fait qui ne connut une
cohabitation en clair parce que ce qui
avait été fait sous chirac c'est à dire
que on avait échangé de changer le
calendrier c'est à dire que les
législatives arrivait dans la foulée de
la présidentielle pour éviter justement
le problème de cohabitation
donc normalement le risque est
minime en revanche ça peut ça peut tout
à fait arriver
maintenant je ne lis pas dans le marc de
café c'est un peu prématuré normalement
si les français élisent macron c'est
qu'ils considèrent qu' ils peuvent lui
donner une majorité
cependant certains peut-être voteront
pour lui parce qu'ils ne veulent pas de
marine le pen mais pour autant ils ne
voudront pas l'empêcher l'ordre ont
empêché de gouverner bon je ne suis pas
dans la tête des millions de français
sont ouverts je ne sais pas c'est vrai
que c'est une vraie question est alors
une autre question de patson ilunga
bonjour merci de nous avoir écrit
comment est-ce qu emmanuel macron compte
défendre un projet qu'il n'a pas réalisé
pendant cinq ans à l'envers comme oui
alors jugement alors
alors ça dépend de quel projet par tous
cas pour le président sortant c'est
toujours plus difficile de voile à faire
valoir enfin de défaillance et
exerçait d'entre deux tours bien sûr
alors ce qu'il a pour lui ce qu'il n'a
pas ce qu'il a pour lui c'est quand même
la crise beaucoup jugeront diront qu'il
est qu'ils n'étaient pas bons mais
d'autres quand même je pourrais regarder
la réalité en face sur le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte quand même l'état a été
présent c'est à dire que emmanuel macron
n'est pas social pendant la crise du
crédit oui la crise que vit le manuel
macro est passé de libéral à étatiste en
quelque sorte à dire que il a permis aux
entreprises de ne pas faire faillite il
a tout fait pour ne pas re confiner les
français
voilà le d'une explosion de la dette
aussi voilà alors bien sûr mais j'ai
envie de dire on ne casse pas faire une
omelette sans casser l'élan coûte le
quoi qu'il en coûte base d'ailleurs la
formule était bien trouvé après bien sûr
il n'a pas pu faire sa réforme des
retraites il n'a pas pu réformer comme
il le voulait il a fait des erreurs
personnelles des erreurs de langage
on l'a dit cent fois d'arrogance etc
il a fait des fautes 1 par exemple le
sujet de la pl sur les allocations pour
le logement ça a été des erreurs il a
fait des erreurs politiques mais
globalement pour avoir traversé une
crise que vides crise sanitaire une
guerre en ukraine et une présidence de
l'europe bon c'est pas totalement nuls
comme bilan bien sûr il manque il manque
beaucoup de choses à son collier on va
dire à ça
à sa couronne de lauriers bien
évidemment
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs j'entendais
clovis tout à l'heure qui disait
macron soit soit les gens me détestent
soit les gens lui leur donne quitus
parce qu'ils considèrent que dans le
fond c'est celui qui s'est pas trop mal
débrouillé alors pour revenir au débat
de l'entre-deux-tours de ce soir qui je
le rappelle sera à suivre aussi sur sur
france 24 et sur ce live
on le sait les choses ont été
extrêmement préparer codifié donc entre
les journalistes donc de france
télévisions et de tf1 mais aussi les
équipes de marine le pen et d' emmanuel
macron
il était d'accord sur un point le fait
que la journaliste anne-sophie lapix il
n'en voulait pas et donc on a une
question à ce sujet de valence que
pensez-vous du rejet d'anne sophie lapix
de ce débat parce qu'elle est et dont la
récente admissibles c'est inadmissible
on n'est pas sous l'eau et rtf ou les
candidats décident de qui on mais on
fait comme
modérateur modératrice d'autant qu
objectivement
lorsque vous faites ce genre d'exercice
vous n'êtes pas dans votre rôle de
journaliste même si c'est honorifique
parce que vous présentez ce débat donc
pour un gouvernement lui une carrière
grammaire une carrière d'un journaliste
politique parce que vous êtes dans les
archives parce que voilà c'est quand
même voilà c'est que vous êtes quelqu un
journaliste qui a réussi on va dire mais
globalement et ce à tout ce qu'ils ont
fait le disent c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est un rôle de passe-plat
c'est un vice roi je crois qu'à 90
vraiment retraite oui
c'est vraiment on est là assists ils
assistent aux matchs en quelque sorte du
modaire j'eusse il lance les temps de
parole il ans les thèmes mais ils font
pas leur travail de journaliste à dire
qu'il ne ne vont pas avoir la liberté d'
interrompre en disant oui mais ce que
vous dites c'est or anne sophie lapix
même si elle est assez mordante danser
dans ses interviews et ce n'est pas pour
déplaire en tout cas journalistique mans
je ne vois pas pourquoi
elle a elle a été empêchée et je trouve
peut-être que les directions n'aurait
pas dû céder à cela maintenant toutes
les équipes des candidats ont un droit
de regard oui ils ont eu droit entre
tram est
en tout cas et oui c'est une très bonne
journaliste et mais bon c'est des
mauvais signaux quand même parce qu'on
nous parle
en large de démocratie de choisir un
journaliste voilà ça arrive ça arrive
que des partout c'est comme ça il ya des
accointances
les gens se connaissent ils où ils ont
confiance en telle personne bon c'est
humain aussi est-ce que le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours peut véritablement
faire basculer une élection juste
confirmer la tendance si on se met un
peu
voilà perspective historique sinon tu as
raison tu as raison et sereine parce que
c'est vrai que le débat de 74 et 80 est
très important parce qu'il reste des
phrases valéry giscard d'estaing contre
mitterrand à deux reprises donc en 1974
ouais et ses shows qu'elles sont
inversés en 1982 voilà 74 74 et valéry
giscard d'estaing qui
je sais pas si cette phrase était
préparée ou non c'était vous supplie
terrain vous n'avez pas le monopole du
coeur donc il a fait mouche
donc valéry giscard d'estaing a remporté
l'élection ou je ne sais pas si c'est
pour ça mais en tout cas ça a été ça a
pesé dans la balance et puis la revanche
en 82 la fameuse petite phrase de
mitterrand la revanche du serpent à
plumes vous êtes l'homme du passif
donc est d'ailleurs à cette époque
valéry giscard d'estaing 80 au premier
tour et le même score que macron il est
à
28% donc il persuadé de gagner est en
fait mitterrand renverse
renverse la vapeur et est élu
et c'est vraiment dans la fin de la
campagne que
valéry giscard d'estaing
on peut imaginer qu'il peut perdre mais
c'est vraiment au dernier moment comme
quoi il faut rester toujours
autre question de qwerty it reza comment
expliquez vous la montée des idées
extrémistes en france
alors les idées extrémistes d'abord il y
en a toujours eu
et l action française oubliée
voilà il ya eu toujours une extrême
droite alors aujourd'hui il ya le débat
est ce qu'on doit dire extrême droite ou
pas il y en a même un philosophe qui
s'en est mêlé en disant mais non elle
n'est pas d'extrême droite parce que
justement l'extrême droite
c'était c'était justement ce qu'on a
connu avant guerre
c'était quoi ta question déjà
d'accord comment est ce que est ce qu'on
peut
alors les noms mais c'est alors je
dirais plutôt la montée du populisme
parce que la montée du populisme tu la
vois un peu partout tu la vois aux états
unis tu la vois en pologne tu la vois en
hongrie tu l'as vu en italie et à
l'épreuve des faits le populisme ça ne
marche pas c'est à dire qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont essayé de renverser la table
ils l'ont fait mais on a vu le résultat
donc c'est une denrée qui ne dure pas
longtemps le populisme et pourtant il ya
un fantasme qui qui qui est encore là et
en france le populisme n'est pas passé
c'est à dire que
la l'extrême droite en tout cas le voeu
le rassemblement national ou front
national était a toujours été un chiffon
rouge qui a fait peur mais jamais et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des français qui
disent mais pourquoi pas essayer des
gens censés vous disent mais pourquoi
pas essayer le rassemblement national on
les a tous essayé la gauche la droite le
centre ça marche pas c'est toujours la
politique du compromis
voilà et pourquoi pas essayer est ce que
le populisme passe en france réponse
dimanche soir
boris mamadi payer nous écrit aussi
roselyne quels sont vos analyses face à
la déclaration du président ukrainien
dont volodymyr zelensky qui soutient
emmanuel macron par rapport à marine le
pen cette déclaration aura-t-elle un
impact sur les électeurs de le pen ben
écoutez comme romain emmanuel macron
considère que vladimir poutine soutient
marine le pen
bassée
un partout la balle au centre non pas
parce que il le soutient il les soutient
parce que d'abord c'est le président
français et qu'il a été enfin qu'il est
il a exercé la présidence de l'europe
donc qui a joué je pense que manuel
macron a dû jouer un rôle important
enfin en tout cas au regard de deux
hélices qui alors qu'il qu'il le
soutienne stricto sensu je ne sais pas
ce qu'il a est-ce que j'ai loupé quelque
chose que j'avais pas vu moi non plus
passionnant donc je ne sais pas j'ai pas
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire sur la
crise ukrainienne sait qu emmanuel
macron ça pour le coup c'est plutôt à
son actif oui tous les soirs et c'est ça
plutôt suez ces cinq jours les gestions
actions et notamment sur cette crise du
clean et moi l'a écrasé 7 cette campagne
présidentielle ouais complètement savent
sur quoi est ce que marine le pen du
coût pour l attaque et si ce n'est du
coup sûr les crises internationales
parce que ça pour le coup il a plutôt
bien géré c'est sur quoi parfois
peut-être ouais tu peux te le côté
l'élite l'élite qui est déconnecté
elles veulent toutes les reproches que
qu'elle lui fait d'habitude c'est à dire
qu'ils n'essaient pas écouter les
français qu'ils ne les comprend pas qui
les a montés les uns contre les autres
c'est le grand argument du rassemblement
national monter les français les uns
contre les autres alors on voit bien
aujourd'hui là qu'il ya aussi il ya deux
visions donc de france donc s'il
rassemblement si marine le pen était
élue je ne crois pas que ce serait la
paix et la félicité dans tout pays il y
aurait des affrontements il y aurait des
comptes des pour donc voilà c'est
question perso est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup
de français au final qui se décident
véritablement l'issue du débat de
l'entre-deux tours
quand tu dis que des questions
personnelles d'un média grâce à moi ces
macabres ah c'est ça ta question
oui
alors c'est difficile je suis pas son 2
je suis pas dans le cachet d'une petite
souris dans les urnes mais non je pense
que quand même les gens ils vont pas au
premier tour je comprends qu'il ya un
moment allez on est devant 12 bulletins
bon on en prend 4,5 et puis là on a une
pulsion mais intel intel franchement là
quand vous avez depuis quinze jours vous
savez que c'est marine le pen
emmanuel macron soit il vous ils vous
file tous les deux des boutons et vous
votez pas soit il y en a un qui vous
file des boutons et pas l'autre soit
vous dites c'est la peste et le choléra
et vous n'allez pas voter donc voyez
entre ces solutions là je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient une pulsion l'isoloir à ce
moment là lorsque vous avez un tel choix
à faire dans un tel moment avec une
telle un tel écart de vision en tout cas
est ce que tu dirais que c'est enfin le
débat que tout le monde attend depuis
mars à lille en pagne oui quand même
franchement
pas ce que tu vois quand il ya des
débats où ils sont 10 12 c'est
insupportable parce que tu as
l'impression de faire un dîner avec des
experts comptables d'intel qui dira mois
ces cinq cent mille fonctionnaires moi
c'est 100 milles et puis alors la
contribution machin le truc alors vous
êtes l'adema qui se fier vous ressortez
avec un vous êtes obligés d'aller
prendre un doliprane en disant bon alors
là que faut-il et en plus après vous
êtes censés aller à l'antenne pour faire
un débrief de tout ça donc
généralement bon voilà c'est un peu
casse pieds là quand vous avez deux
personnes totalement diamétralement
opposées qui s'opposent pour la deuxième
fois où il ya un véritable suspense non
pas dans le résultat si on regarde les
sondages mais un suspense dans le fait
que s que marine le pen a repris à
retravailler ses dossiers dans quel état
elle arrive elle qui vous l'êtes qui
veut gouverner en mère de famille
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il va pouvoir
tenir sa langue et être moins arrogants
être calme tout en jouant le professeur
sans l'humilier elles n'étant pas trop
agressive c'est vrai qu'on attend tout
ça et c'est très intéressant de voir
comment ils se sont préparés et ce soir
on aura devant nous des gens qui auront
préparé leur punchline préparer leurs
arguments préparer leurs attaques
préparer leur défense c'est ça qui va
être assez c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
duel enfin tellement plu que les arènes
autour de nous on a une dernière
question peut-être pour conclure
roselyne sur ton pronostic pour nous
en tout cas on peut rappeler les
intentions de vote selon notre
partenaire ipsos au prince taille attend
d'abord à sa chaleur d'eau on se mouille
pas donc 54% pour emmanuel macron votre
46 pour marine le pen en tout cas aux
dernières au dernière nouvelle fois
c'est en tout cas les chiffres qui
revenait beaucoup ces derniers jours on
va voir les lieux suivre ce cet après
midi puisque les chiffres sont pour les
intentions de vote son hub de l'été
tous les jours vers 16h30 les 43 on
devrait avoir le chiffre et puis pour la
participation je vous le rappelle ipsos
sopra steria notre partenaire donné en
tout cas hier 71 % de participation au
second tour merci beaucoup roselyne
d'avoir participé à ce 5e live de notre
émission france 2022 l'heure du choix
merci à vous tous de l'avoir suivi
d'avoir voilà nous avoir fait part de
vos commentaires de vos questions
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux à new débriefer sur ce live pour
qu'on s'améliore sans cesse et je vous
le rappelle ne manquez pas notre édition
spéciale qui commence ce soir à 20h15
heure de paris à suivre non seulement
sur notre antenne mais aussi sur ce live
donc vous pouvez rester branché voilà
tout l'après midi jusqu'à 20h15 et à
suivre donc dans la foulée le fameux
débat de l'entre-deux tours entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen à 21h
pétantes heure de paris merci à tous et
à très bientôt
[Musique]